great white sharks
is there any sea beast so feared by
humans
great whites like these here off the
coast of South Africa in an area called
false Bay can reach 20 feet in length
and weigh up to 5,000 pounds
that's more than a pickup truck but
slightly less than a luxury SUV add this
to the fact that great whites can't
sprint through the water it speeds up to
43 miles per hour and it's no wonder
we're afraid of sharks but should we be
honey let's face it they have great
vision they're curious like cats and
they love to taste things that get their
attention but many scientists believe
they don't like to eat humans they feel
about humans the way most humans feel
about lima beans there's something to
eat out of desperation the fact is great
whites sometimes taste humans for the
same reason they taste other things like
motors or boats they're ampullae of
Lorenzini prompt them to taste it of
course the ampullae of Lorenzini are
gel-filled
electro receptors found all around the
Sharks snout and head that's these
smaller pores you see here these
receptors are extremely sensitive to
electrical discharges even as small as
point zero zero five micro volts that
means anything that gives off the
tiniest electrical charge has to be
checked out including all living
creatures in the sea forget humans and
motor boats if you want to see one
little literally let's talk about seals
we know that some whale species engage
in what's called breaching leaping out
of the water but did you know great
white sharks can reach as well look at
these false pay great whites put on a
show as they go after a seal decoy being
pulled by a boat if humans are lima
beans to sharks then seals are a double
hot fudge ice cream sundae with three
cherries on top luckily we're yeah lima
beans